let's deal with 1 Corinthians 15:2
24-28 here's the link to their Bible
let's read you're going to learn a lot
folks if you listen I promise you're
going to learn about end times the
return of Christ the Resurrection The
glorification of Believers how to
interpret scripture how not to interpret
scripture trusting the Holy Spirit to
enable me to bless you as he makes my
sound pleasing to your ears and
strengthens my throat all right here it
goes let's read the
context this is talking about the end of
the age when the Lord Jesus destroys all
his enemies and His Last enem Enemy is
death he's going to destroy and abolish
physical death there'll be no more death
then the age to come will be ushered in
that new age where the Lord will
transform the heavens and the Earth
making them new qualitatively it's not
going to be a new Heaven being brought
into existence and a new Earth being
brought into existence it's this Heaven
and Earth trans formed like you are made
a new creature but it's the same you
transformed so that in that age it will
be perfect righteousness perfect
peace perfect
bliss deathlessness immortality moral
incorruptibility no more sin no more
Satan no more Scandal that's the age to
come so notice what Paul says is going
to happen when the Lord Jesus brings in
that age okay here you go 1 Corinthians
15 24-28
and by the way the entire
chapter of 1 Corinthians 15 is about the
general resurrection of
Believers what to expect and why you
should believe in the resurrection
that's the entire theme and how Jesus's
resurrection is the proof the Divine
impr promod God's niil obot to use
Catholic terminology that there is a
resurrection at the End of the Age
what's the proof God raised Jesus
physically bodily to immortality where
Jesus now experiences
human immortality human deathlessness
because he's still a man with a physical
body made Immortal as a
guarantee that we who are in Christ will
be raised physically to be like him
deathless Immortal morally Incorruptible
so Jesus is the first fruits of the
batch of the Harvest of the redeem who
be resurrected to possess physical
bodies like his bodies under the control
and power and Dominion of the spirit
that's why they're spiritual bodies not
under the control Dominion of what Paul
calls the Su your soul because here Paul
uses flesh and blood and soul to mean
that evil sinful tendency and
influence that's the entire theme of 1
Corinthians 15
read it from verse 1- 58 he's talking
about the resurrection of Believers
being anchored in the resurrection of
Christ so if you know Christ has been
resurrected take it to heart you'll be
resurrected but if Christ has not been
raised then your faith is useless it's
vain because you have no guarantee
you'll be raised so then give up on
Christianity and just party that's what
Paul says I'm not exaggerating he says
that so does everyone understand what
the theme of first Cor 15 happens to be
because I can't read all 58 verses do
you guys understand what the theme
is everyone got understand the theme
it's about the
resurrection that we in Christ will be
raised physically bodily will be under
the complete dominion and control of the
Holy Spirit that's why it's spiritual
bodies bodies that are under the power
of the spirit not solish bodies bodies
under the pernicious evil influence of
sin which brings about death and moral
corruption and Decay and the proof and
guarantee that we will be raised God
raised Jesus physically bodily and Jesus
is the first fruits of the Harvest of
the redeemed that guarantees our
Resurrection but then Paul says in 1
Corinthians 15:12 to19 if Christ has not
been raised then you believe in vain
your faith is of no use it's useless
Stop Believing stop being a Christian go
live it up party because you have no
Assurance of the Resurrection if Christ
has not been raised but glory to the
father Christ has been raised so we too
will be raised so you better live in
obedience to the Lord so we got that
right we got that that's the theme of 1
Corinthians 15 because I want to go to
that particular section that's being
misquoted okay here it goes from their
Bible 1 Corinthians 15 24- 28 okay next
the end when he h hands over the king in
fact let me read 20 to 23 so you can
understand what he's talking about you
guys
ready 1 Corinthians 15 20 23 in their
Bible but now Christ has been raised
from the dead the first fruits of those
who have fallen asleep in death now what
does it mean first
fruits right you'd have the first fruits
of the spring Harvest Right you know
that your field would produce a
plentiful crop because around Harvest
Time in the spring you'd have the first
batch of the Harvest and if your first
batch was good then that guaranteed that
the rest of the batch the Harvest would
be good and plentiful so Jesus is the
first batch the the first fruits of the
Harvest of the redeemed will be raised
to life you understand the imagery here
as the Holy Spirit guides me to speak
without
error so Christ the first fruits of
those who have fallen asleep in death
he's been raised for since death came
through a man
Adam resurrection of De also comes
through a man for just as in Adam all
are dying so also in Christ all will be
made alive but each one in own proper
order Christ the first fruit so it's
saying there is an order time first
comes the first fruits afterward the
rest of the Harvest and who's the
Harvest afterward those who belong to
the Christ during his presence his
appearance so do you understand the
context so
now first came the first fruits of the
Dead Jesus then the rest of the Harvest
of those who are asleep they will then
awaken and be raised but when will they
be awakened and when will they be raised
now let's read
24:28 next the end when he hands over
the kingdom to his God and Father so
Paul is saying when the rest of the Dead
are resurrected and death has been
abolished and destroyed done away with
then Jesus will hand the kingdom to his
God and father when he is brought to
nothing all government and all authority
and power now you want you guys want me
to go into meet right
according to the promise of scripture
the time will come there'll no longer be
any competing opposing
governments agencies and kingdoms
because when Jesus comes he will abolish
all other rule all other government
Authority and kingdoms and the only
Kingdom and government and Rule will be
that of God on Earth forever and ever
it'll be one government one Kingdom one
Dominion one Authority on Earth the
kingdom of God and that Kingdom will
last forever and will never be
replaced so when he comes all these
governments and agencies and authorities
will be abolished especially all the
governments and authorities who seek to
oppose the rule of God legislate
contrarily to the will of God and
legislate sin and
Abomination to their shame and
humilation in their war against God and
His
rule you with me so
far okay so that's what will happen when
Jesus comes he will destroy all these
governments the American government the
Saudi Arabian government the Russian
government all governments that oppose
God's Rule and legislate contrarily to
the will of God to their shame and only
God's rule will be Implement fully
without hindrance without opposition
when Christ comes and raises the dead
and his rule will remain on Earth
forever so far we got it right okay
because there's a lot of me I can't go
through this too
fast 25 for he must rule as king so he
rules now notice Jesus is ruling as king
from heaven so they he though he allows
these governments and agencies and
kingdoms to rule even in opposition to
him he's still Sovereign over them
Supreme over them Almighty over them but
he's allowing them to continue for a
season and for a reason so he must rule
as king from God's Throne the father's
Throne until God has put all enemies
under his feet and The Last Enemy death
is to be brought to nothing so The Last
Enemy that will be destroyed is death
now let's unpack that you guys want meat
right you guys want
meat you guys want meat right what's The
Last Enemy that will be
destroyed exactly anach Chung imagine we
the greatest nation has to receive Food
a baby formal from another
Nation The Last Enemy is death right now
do you understand the heart of God there
I don't know if you understood it let's
see if you you understood the art of God
God hates death death was not God's will
for mankind death is an enemy that God
hates but death exists because of Satan
and Adam and Eve who disobeyed God and
brought death into being but notice the
heart of God death is an enemy that he
hates and he wants to destroy and will
destroy which means that God God's
desire for mankind wasn't that men would
die that wasn't his will for
us but that's the consequence of our sin
the soul that sins shall die Ezekiel 18
verse 4 and
20 for the wages of sin is death Romans
6:23 so you see do you see the heart of
God being reflected in God's perfect
word the Holy Bible is this Bible not
beautiful because it reveals to you the
heart of your Creator God hates death
death is his
enemy he did not
desire death to exist he did not want
death to enter the world he did not want
his creatures to experience death but
because of rebellion this is the
consequence of death that's why in
Hebrews
24- 15 we are told it is the devil who
has authority over death why because in
Hebrews 24- 15 it was the devil that
instigated Adam and Eve to sin thereby
bringing death into the world so he
caused death to enter by tempting Adam
and E to
sin that's Hebrews 24- 15 are we getting
it is it making sense guys before I move
on I can't move on if you're not getting
it
see the heart of God